you
[Music]
I'm going to talk a little bit about
intent media the company I work for
we're based where startup based in
downtown I promise this first section
isn't a sales pitch unless anyone's a
chief marketing officer in which case
it's definitely a sales pitch and you
can come and talk to me afterwards what
I want to get to is kind of an
understanding of why machine learning is
really important to us right and why the
data science is Recor to what we do and
then some of the motivate some of the
problems that that we face and you come
up and the two kind of actual things I
want to talk about one is a scholar
library we built called doublespeak
which is really around feature
extraction and kind of why we built it
and what what it is to do and then this
kind of very natural pattern if you
solve one problem and it's really
successful and it leads to lots of
people using it and at least two other
problems down the line so the next one
was about having to deal with thousands
of models that get changed very often
and so how we had to automate the
pipeline okay so first things first
credit where credit's due I didn't do a
lot of this work but there was a core
team there's a lot of other people
around the edges but I think these are
the people who really did most of the
work and all the heavy lifting was done
by jockey gabrielle and sebastian and in
particular some of this is Sebastian's
brainchild so if anyone has any really
deep technical questions see me in the
office hours and if I can't answer them
I'll give you these guys emails you John
and I are the data scientists and like
good data scientists our role was mostly
to like poke our noses in once in a
while and make things extra difficult
for the engineers so introduction to
intent who are what do we do so the
basic premise of what we do is founded
on the idea that almost everything on
the web is optimized for the average
user and just like there's no such thing
as a family with 2.4 children that there
isn't really an average user but that's
the way the world works that's the way
everything in our life works and if we
could undo that if we can start
optimizing for individuals somehow we
could do better and you do better
hopefully for the website doing whatever
your business metrics are but also for
the user you know we start to get
treated more like you want to be treated
that's obviously a super great lofty
goals that's great to say but what we
actually do so what we actually do is
we've built a predictive intelligence
platform which basically scores users
real time on a site and we return in 10
score which is something between 1 and
10 which can mean various different
things
come as no surprise for this audience
that this is the machine learning this
is the data science and one example it's
very common a lot of our partners is
what's the likelihood that this user is
going to purchase on your site right
that seems to be something most people
care about especially if you're commerce
side so this is a kind of a good example
but it could be various other things
like likelihood that they're going to
show up somewhere else likely that
they're going to put this other things
likelihood they're going to parents
likely gonna stay on the page and so on
I should say that like you know 10% is
good but it definitely doesn't get you
from the whole population down to an
individual but it's a step in the right
direction so like it's allowing you to
kind of treat users differently and
that's kind of what we're getting in so
the types of experiences that our
partners are commonly using this form
imagine it was like the prediction was
likelihood to purchase then if you're on
the extreme high ends of the scale you
give them a you give users are very
commerce to experience you know they
want to book you just keep things out of
the way keep it clean maybe you get them
straight to the cart quicker and on the
other hand if they're not likely to book
then they're maybe want to do something
else
right maybe they're still searching and
you want to treat them all like a search
engine and the media in our business was
kind of what we found it so we kind of
provide an ad network and that's kind of
where a lot of the revenue comes in and
so you can kind of start to target the
ads to the people who they're most
useful for this is just one example
right there's lots of other use cases
you could start to think of and actually
there's a lot of different a lot of
partners are starting to get kind of
really into you know slicing up the data
in different ways by these scores to do
different types of things who do we work
with well we're definitely in the travel
vertical for sure we've got pretty good
coverage in North America and Europe and
we're expanding out in Latin America and
Asia Pacific and the only real thing to
take away from this slide is that we
have a lot of searches right so we make
these predictions a lot so it's
approaching one in one-and-a-half
billion searches a month each of those
searches is multiple events which have
with multiple predictions so this is
really something that happens at the web
scale so that's intent media as a kind
of concept how does data science fit
into this like where does it come from
and what do we actually do so the data
we use is collected from our partners
and so it's either a JavaScript tag on
the page or a pixel that's dropped on it
that fires events back to us those
events are logged and that's that log
data is what we train
so we'll train a model so the example
prediction rigging a likelihood to
convert these models are then used for
real time predictions and when we say
real time we mean real time in the sense
of page load time right so there's
obviously all networking effects you've
got to get this this score back to the
page and so on but for the just the
predictions we have an SLO of 10
milliseconds so these predictions the
real time inference has to be fast it
also has to happen at high scale and
high throughput right so we're peaking
out at about 160,000 a minute and that's
growing really rapidly over the last 12
months so this has to be sort of very
horizontally scalable once you've made
the predictions various things happen
one growing use case is we just passed
the prediction back to the website and
say like hey guys do your UX based on
this whatever it is we want to do you've
got the you've got the data to do it a
lot of our partners we will provide
certain UX is based on that experience
for them so we'll show ads to the right
people or will show conversion boosting
experiences maybe get a promo code if
you're on the fence things like that and
then in addition to working out what
type of UX to show then like this
subtype so which type of are you gonna
see which type of promo code you're
going to see and those are all the sort
of decisions that have to happen real
time and the real emphasis I want to
make here is that this is all what
powers the business right nunn of nunn
of intent media would have been possible
without this so it does sit sort of at
the very core of what we do ok so
background stuff aside the thing I want
to talk about first is a Scala library
we built called doublespeak and it does
feature engineering and so one of the
challenges we had was building and
testing features rapidly we want to try
out a feature we want to see if it works
and want to get it out there and I'm
gonna I'm gonna talk you through how we
do it now with double speed I'm also
going to point out a problem that comes
from versioning features and trying to
serve models and publish models real
time if you've done this before this
will be and are very familiar if you
just haven't done that publishing step
very often do something you might not
have thought about so when you think of
feature extraction as a step in a
modeling pipeline what do you want it to
be well the software engineers in the
room are going to want it to be robust
right we live in a real messy world or
data comes in it's incomplete
you've got nulls all over the place
right you want to make sure it's robust
to all these things
it should be production level code right
this shouldn't be something that like
eyes at a science the data scientists
have hacked together in ten minutes and
then I'm going to put it up there
because it worked on my laptop right it
means to be core code so it should have
all the things you want should be
maintainable all you should have
continuous integration you should be
things like that on the other hand as a
user I definitely want to be able to do
this quickly right the whole point of
being able to do this is to rapidly
experiment and get things wrong ten
times but at least the 11th time it
works and any of each one of those time
takes a month this is gonna be a problem
it should be flexible so the the the
types of events that we're getting I
don't want a different feature
extraction for each of them I want to be
able to like you reuse the code I've
used over and over again for different
types of features of different types of
events and I wanted to be feature-rich
because at the end of the Emporer lazy I
don't want to have to deal with
interpolation by hand every time and I'm
used to using SK learn which has all
these fantastic features in there and I
want all of them those two things are
very different sets of requirements and
actually finally one that does
everything together is is surprisingly
challenging but the other thing that
challenging is making sure this works
fast at inference really fast so we
built double speak so double speak is
the Scala library what it does is to
find a feature extractor set and I'll
talk a little bit about what that is in
a second and well you can use this basic
object to extract features from rdd's so
if you're not used to spark or Scala
rdd's are kind of one of the distributed
data systems they have but it can also
be used for individual records real time
and the key point there is that you can
you can use it to extract features from
individual records without spark so you
don't have to build spark into your
real-time inference section you get some
things for free
so it free in the sense that you already
had to do them so you may as well output
it so you can encode all the features
from batch jobs and you can see what
those are like and you can get all these
features summaries and you can see you
know how often certain categorical
features appear and what this you know
the averages and stuff are this is very
much like the dot described on a pendant
so I'm going to show you some actual
code or well first sorry when I say this
is easy to use I really mean it's easy
to use because like I'm the barrier
because
I it's not easy enough for me to use and
they have to fix it and it comes with a
whole load of all the things you want
lie computers transformers normalization
and stuff like that and actually almost
all that's built in as defaults that you
can then override and it leads to a very
concise code if you haven't seen scarlet
just read this is pseudocode you don't
need to see the details this is the
basic object that you build okay so it's
a feature set scarless strongly typed so
you have to give it a type of the object
it's going to apply to so in this case
it's impression it's just some object
that contains the data you're going to
pull your features from I gave as an
example this validators thing here
actually is a happen single value as a
default so you can ignore it but you can
put something in here that says ignore
features that have this property so
there's a feature that you get in it
always the same value and the training
set just drop it don't even worry about
it
there's too many nulls get rid of it and
then in the next three lines we've got
three features the first one is a
categorical feature is a numerical
feature there's a binary feature and all
you need to define is the name of the
feature and the second argument is the
function that returns the value of that
future as an example to explain kind of
what else is available if you wanted you
can override the default transformers
for a categorical and say well how are
you going to encode this but you don't
need to and you don't need to specify
normalization or anything like this in a
single line you've defined a feature
extractor and you can have as many of
these as you want and it really is that
easy so if I have an idea for a feature
it's one line of code
and I can write it down in about 10
seconds some nice features about this
some of this is to do a double speak
some of this is to do with Scala but one
thing that's very nice is this is being
strongly typed it means it's very robust
to schema changes so if someone changes
something about the impression type
someone changes I think earlier we
talked about int going to string for
some element of it or someone adds an
element or removes an element this it'll
fail at compile time so you don't have
to worry about runtime errors coming
coming at you
it's robust in another sense that if you
have a categorical that you value for a
categorical that you seen in real time
that you didn't see the training data
it'll just default into this other
category in that especially
you roll up a lot of the longtail
categoricals that long tail is big for
us that we have a lot of categoricals
that are extremely high cardinality so
you can think of like airport codes
there are tens of thousands of airport
codes and if you think of origin
destination Airport code suddenly
talking about hundreds of thousands of
categories and that has a very long tail
it has all the kind of default encoding
and interpolation and normalization that
you want so you can just use it out of
the box you don't have to like start
putting in stuff by hand and you
automatically get these feature
summaries right so and I say
automatically in the sense that it has
to calculate things like the mean and
the standard deviation to be able to do
normalization so you may as well output
them and be able to see them and look at
them gives you a way of debugging
features quite efficiently so that was
like the one piece was just this feature
set nice so as I said this is the core
to it how does that actually like what
does it look like you were using it for
something real so the color coding here
is anything that's red is double
speaking the rest of its just a
bog-standard Scala code right there's
nothing special about it so we have to
find this feature set for these three
nice little features and that was the
basic thing we needed to do you do next
is load in an RDD of these basic data
this is your training data that you're
going to test on or are you going to
train on and then there's a doublespeak
a function called our DD extractor which
you pass this feature set into and that
can apply to an RDD and when all it does
is turn their produces for you an
extractor object which has in it a data
frame ready for use in predictions
already for using training so the last
two rows are just taking that training
data set joining it to whatever your
labels are going to be and then hitting
train so it really does kind of fit very
nicely with the ML live world so this
object this thing that we get this RTD
extractor what's in it right so there is
the Royal features that's really just if
you want to look at them and you can
kind of do some analytics on it and it's
kind of useful sometimes to say like hey
I've got this complicated you know
structured object like an avro object or
something is hard to reason about if I
turn it into a data frame I can do those
also cool analytics with it the
reference features are the thing that
you actually plug in to a training and
it's just basically got this features
column at the end which is the vector
the feature vector that you're looking
for for this example I turned off
normalization just so that like you can
kind of see how
the one hot encoding works but you know
you get the picture this is just the
feature that features column that you're
looking for and the other thing it
produces an extraction metadata and this
is all the things like what categories
did I see for a particular categorical
what was the encoding for it what was
the mean and standard deviation if I'm
using standard normalization for a
particular value and so on and those are
nice to have from a kind of debugging
point of view but they're actually
necessary to be able to test and do
inference with so we'll see how that
comes later so this was the training how
does it work when you want to test it by
test I mean batch testing so it's almost
as simple right you know you have this
object there's a dot extract function or
a method on it which you can apply to
other data and the key point there is
that other this extract method uses the
original category the original
categoricals the original normalization
from the training data and this is where
you can get things mixed up if you're
kind of not concentrating this is where
you can accidentally only use categories
that exist in the test data not in the
training data or things like that so
that's super easy the whole purpose of
doing this was really to focus on the
real-time inference so how does it work
at kind of real-time one of the things
we wanted to avoid was having to have a
spark dependency in the real-time world
because it really feels overkill to have
a single event come in one at a time
load that into a spark object spin up
the whole spark sort of dependency and
then just to make a single inference on
it so it's almost as simple you will
load this metadata which is this sort of
artifact that we had that gets loaded
with the model okay and we'll talk about
how this model gets published and the
metadata goes with it in a second and
from it you can apply a record extractor
method right so this is just for a
single method a single record I want to
extract features and that is something
that is built out of that metadata and
once I have that I can apply a single
impression I get whatever it happens to
be a vector in this case and that vector
is ready for pushing into a serialized a
serialize model for example cool one
thing and I don't know if my I don't
know where the link is somewhere in here
is linked to a Spotify
code open source code that doesn't mean
very super than similar cold feature on
I highly recommend anyone looks at it if
you're interested in any of this
especially since that is open source and
this is not yet open source so you don't
have much of a choice I just wanted to
point out the kind of key differences so
first of all they're featuring the
feature encode is much more feature-rich
they go into a lot of natural language
stuff and they have a lot more kind of
features built into it so it's great
this was geared much more to getting the
real-time inference stuff sort of super
fast that was really the core today
again so when it comes we're discussing
open sourcing and it'll be a discussion
next year as to whether it belongs as a
separate thing or whether it's just
additional functionality we put in there
so I want to kind of emphasize how
successful this was as an engineering
product or an engineering effort so the
old way of doing feature extraction was
like just building the functions and
testing them extensively and and then
having it there and then once you've got
one you've got another one another one
another one then trying to wrap them all
up together and trying to make sure all
the vectors were consistent and so on
which was painful and we ended up having
about 10,000 plus lines of feature
extraction code and when we translated
that or doublespeak which is the same
features it went down by an order of
magnitude bigger and more importantly
the number of test lines of code that we
had to support those features went down
from like 45,000 plus and I still don't
think we had proper coverage down to
like less than 3,000 and Mac gets it
small enough that you can get your head
around it and you can kind of really
reason about you know are there big gaps
is there anything we're missing are
there any edge cases that we haven't
covered and as a user by far the biggest
thing was to get a new feature into
production went from an effort of days
two weeks two minutes so I can I can
code up a new feature that I've just
decided hey I think this is going to be
great and assuming I've done some
analysis and think it's a good idea I
can kind of one line of code and commit
to getting the whole continuous
integration process happens and it'll be
pushed to production which is amazing
it's exactly what we wanted really fast
experimentation you know try lots of
things some of its going to stick and
work which is fantastic however it leads
to this massive headache from an
operational standpoint and the headache
is now you've got lots of people like me
changing the features all the time so
the models are constantly changing
and so you have to deal with that you
have to deal with the like being able to
publish and deploy models very rapidly
all the time and keeping sure making
sure that the model versions and the
future versions are in sync and that's
something that like if you get wrong
you get very wrong so let's let's talk
about that let's talk about what happens
when you think a feature is I you know
offline train some feature Bilson
features training a model and I want to
deploy it how does how does that process
work so typically these are the steps
you think of in an offline training
world right I load some data extract
some features i train a model many
various things to it I tested and
validating stuff but you know assuming
things are good I want to push that
model up to production and in our case
production is some prediction service
that you know dealing with the
prediction requests and the inference
the two steps extract the feature in the
train the model are distinct steps
usually right and they're certainly
similarly they're distinct steps at the
real-time world you need to find the
right model and I'll talk about like why
we have multiple different models in a
second and you better extract the right
features for that model in case anyone
hasn't thought this through I'm going to
do like a really trivial example of why
this can go wrong so imagine we have the
blue model up in production it's
constantly serving it's good it happens
to be super trivial it's got three
weights and I over at six weights and is
expecting a six vector I never give it a
six vector you'll make a prediction and
everything's good
meanwhile in the offline world I've
retrained the model and for whatever
reason I now have a model that only
takes six weights maybe I've lost a
category in a categorical maybe for some
reason I decide I'm gonna delete a
feature and I don't need that feature
anymore now I've got like of feature
extractors that will produce a five
vector and a model that's expecting a
five actor and in production in
currently-serving models system I have
things that are expecting a six vector
now you see immediately that there's no
the only way to do to push this to
production to make sure they're always
in sync because if you ever tried to do
one first and then the other you're
going to end up in this period where
something is just not consistent and
you're either giving it five weights and
a six vector which I mean if you may
think the robust isn't going to fail but
it is going to produce nonsense and
that's kind of worse than failing
because it looks like it's a prediction
it look
like it's working but it's actually just
complete crap and that's that
inconsistent state persists until you
manage to push up the version of the
features that go with the model now this
kind of deployment problem wouldn't be
the end of the world if it was like one
deployment happened once in a while and
it was only going to take like a few
seconds to go up and you'd be like okay
it's a few seconds of inconsistency but
but you know there's something we can
deal with the challenge we face is it's
not once in a while we have thousands of
models and we deploy them every day and
that little bit of like inconsistency of
during a deployment can be like
absolutely killer so the key takeaway
here is you really do need to keep the
feature extraction and the model that
you've trained in sync right those those
really have to be part of the same
process
they can't be different and so
doublespeak helps us a little bit in the
sense that the feature extraction code
is all static scholar code so when we
deploy something it all that all that
future extraction logic goes with it and
the only thing that's left that you need
to load is the serialized model and the
accompanying metadata that the features
are built from so as long as you keep
the metadata and the serialize model
together now you can be sure it's going
up consistency and consistently now
that's not super trivial right but at
least it's kind of encompassed what you
need to keep together in a very concise
way and it's all serialized right so you
don't have to worry about too much about
different pieces of code getting up in
different times okay so this was all
this is kind of one half of the talk
this was all on the feature extraction
side and the kind of library we built to
kind of help us do this and stuff one of
the challenges that we were facing
before all this was a proliferation of
models right so we were going from like
originally 10 ish models to hundreds of
models or an hour at thousands of models
and all these models we train every day
so you know low thousands of models they
all get kind of configured by hand once
they're done you schedule them and they
go you can kind of keep track of that as
a group just but when you do that and
then you've on added on top of it that
that number is growing and all of them
are constantly becoming very different
because people like me are adding
different features and changing features
it becomes a configuration nightmare and
just keeping track of what models are
where what you know partner use what
and what the result was and this one
failed and I don't know how many days it
failed for and I don't know what was
actually used to make the prediction
becomes a real challenge so why do we
have lots of models that's the first
question why don't we just produce one
model and you know predict on that that
would solve the problem so unfortunately
we don't live in that world because each
of our partners we need to train a model
for them themselves plan has a usually
pretty stingy about sharing data so they
definitely don't want you know different
people getting to a model trained on
their data so every every partner gets
their own own model now that first slide
we saw lots of partners or whatever it
was is like 300 and some like cool 300 I
mean okay that's that's a lot but it's
deal you know you can deal with him the
real problem comes from the fact that
not every partner gets just one model so
each partner could ask for a model for
let's say users likelihood to purchase
hotel when I see them on my flight spa
and and that starts to explode pretty
quickly it gets even worse when they say
like I want that and I also want to know
like what's the likelihood that they're
going to bounce
what slightly they're gonna have another
page view was letting here they're gonna
do something else and something else and
something else so the number of these
models kind of you know goes up
combinatoric lee with the number of
partner is the number of different
products and a number of conversion
products the number of models you're
trying to serve so we have thousands
daily if they were all qualitatively the
same that wouldn't be the end of the
world if there was kind of one universal
set of configurations you could use
right the rest of it becomes a
scheduling issue unfortunately that's
not the case either so you can totally
imagine the amount of data you need to
train a model is going to be very
different from an Expedia of the world
to some small European site which has
very low volumes of traffic so there's
some like cleverness you need to do to
just work out what's the right amount of
data to use for each model but it's
something you can kind of get your head
around and figure out what to do so it's
kind of the length of the training
training datum different models actually
use different features right so now we
have like really distinct models they're
very different from each other from a
kind of functional point of view as well
they have different objectives right the
different model types we've been talking
about this is you know what you what
Expedia considers a purchaser involves
some implicit look ahead window
right you know a purchaser when in the
next 24 hours next 10 10 years I mean
those are very different things and
different partners have different
definitions so actually almost every
part of the model is different for
different different pipelines and then
finally different algorithms right maybe
you try a simple model it works very
well and something like religious
aggression is perfect obviously use the
simplest one and it doesn't work in you
got to use something smarter like you've
got to go to it like a gradient boosted
tree or so on look whatever it happens
to be that works that's the one you're
going to use but now you have lots and
lots of different algorithms that you
need to keep track of as well and if all
this was a one-off for each of these
things that would just become your day
job you do this every time you push
models out and they'd never change and
you were good you keep you busy but you
know it will be very pleasant but the
real killer is that all of this has to
repeat every day right so we we don't
live in an online training world we
batch train and then publish the models
and we've to keep things fresh we train
every day which means we have to worry
about the deployments of thousands of
models every day and so the challenges
we saw about you know publishing models
and getting everything in sync and not
messing it up become quite exacerbated
so here's the kind of picture to have in
your mind right we have this kind of
standard training pipeline I'm gonna
talk a little bit about more about how
we kind of schedule these things and so
on we're in AWS shop so you can play a
game with guessing what the symbols mean
on the side so these are the the sort of
modeling pipelines and we have I put
hundreds here we have thousands of them
live at any one time and the basic steps
along the way a load data we better load
the right data that can be different for
each of these pipelines extract features
the features were using is different
from each of the pipeline's train the
model well the definition of the
objective and the algorithm can be
different from each of the models test
the model the actual definition of what
is a pass what's good enough can can
depend very much on the partners so the
really the only thing that's common to
these these pipelines is the publishing
so I just to actually go ahead and use
it or not right maybe you decide this
one wasn't good enough and you're not
going to do it so what did we do
ROS sorry this was all on the offline
world there's an exactly similar problem
on the online side of things right when
it actually comes to the online
inference so this has to be fast and it
has to work at scale so we use ECS
to kind of you know horizontally scale
but every time a request comes in some
things have to happen so you need to
find the model right so a request comes
in from a partner for a particular
product for a particular prediction
you've got to find the right model for
that you've got to find the right
features that go with that model and
they're going to make the prediction and
the making the prediction means you've
got to remember what the algorithm is
suppose to be using me is to make the
prediction and all that has to happen
fast and so these are this is the
challenge this is why we kind of had all
these thousands the things this is why I
became difficult and so we start
deciding to build something and one of
the reasons I want to like just leave
you it before I start talking about what
the actual infrastructure looks like is
like the scale of some of these things
so the training is big I mean it's not
Google big but it's still tens of
terabytes of training data every day
right so that's a lot we have thousands
of models live right so that's a lot of
models to keep track of it also means
when you get into the thousands you are
starting to expect some to fail and you
have to work out what you gonna do in
those failure cases the predictions have
to be fast so I don't want to try and
pretend that like our response times to
the website at 10 milliseconds but like
our prediction response times internally
is 10 milliseconds that's our SLO and we
have to deploy I mean essentially 100%
of our models get redeployed daily and
the only exception would be that - that
would be ones that actually get deployed
faster than that so if something changed
or there was broken you wanted to deploy
in addition so there would be that -
that would and the last thing is all
this has to be very robust because this
a failure to make a correct prediction
is kind of a really bad thing in the
context of what we do so and you can
imagine you know imagine you're a
partner out there and you've decided
it's you're comfortable serving ads to
people who are predicted to be low value
we start predicting everyone to be low
value and they start seeing ads and they
were about to make a purchase that's
going to really hurt you the other way
is just as bad right if you start saying
hey all these low value people are going
to start getting conversion boosting
experiences that's just a total waste of
time and effort and money that you're
not going to want to spend and even if
our partners have integrated with these
scores and put it into their like
sorting algorithm or their search
results so they're using it for email
retargeting or whatever there starts to
go very
very quickly so we need to be quite
robust and make sure that we're always
serving whatever is the best prediction
we can and also understand that if we
can't serve a good prediction we know
what we know and we know what to do
about that so this will prompted like
dealing with a modeling automated
pipeline and about this is something we
kind of be working on this year and we
finished it up now but like the system
prior to that worked and it was
consistent it was just extremely painful
manually with a lot of pager duty stuff
going off and kind of like several teams
this was their whole job trying to keep
it keep this sort of thing thing afloat
modeling automated pipeline has taken
most of that manual effort away from us
thank God so we use air flow it's funny
I was expecting to have to try and
convince people why air flow is a good
thing but it seems like every third Tork
up here has used air flow so air flow is
great I suggest anyone uses it which
hasn't used it take a look at it
we use it basically for the core
scheduling and just coordinating what's
going on the different steps in it one
interesting thing we found is yeah we
have thousands of models to train and
and that's a long way from every
possible model but the coordination
effort in trying to decide which models
were going to go and what happens
someone wants to add a new model and the
camp manager comes in and said I want to
tweak this model and so on it turned out
just to be easier to train every
possible model it was supported by the
data and that leads to compute overhead
right so we were wasting money on AWS
costs which makes AWS happy but it
actually saves us a huge amount on the
tech ops side and it it you know
warrants the expense the other benefits
are it just means that if anyone wants a
new model it's there it's already been
done and tell you a little bit of a
second why we split these up into
cohorts of training jobs very practical
reason anyway the first step in this is
this prep step which is basically okay
go build up the jar which is got the
latest feature of versions the latest
code this is the thing that's going to
get deployed stick it up in s3 so it's
ready to use it also goes and looks at
our data warehouse and says ok what data
do we actually have you know you know
the last X number of weeks of training
how many of the events that we're going
to train on did we see how many of the
objective events did we see for every
site every partner every combination of
things when which ones of these is
actually sufficient to build a model on
and then go ahead and train
so once we've worked that out we split
these things up into cohorts and the
cohorts is really just to try and get
like roughly equal sized number of
training jobs to go and we train on
spark and then launch those training
jobs so we use Amazon's EMR which is the
elastic MapReduce clusters and we just
basically for each of these modeling
jobs we spin up a new spark cluster
train the model and have the outputs
pushed to s3 and the last thing then is
the publish step when the publish step
is if everything works is trivial
everything works it's just go ahead push
this thing up to ECS the jar up to VCS
and all the new versions are ready and
everything's being version and kept in
sync the only logic that's required here
is actually very important logic is what
happens if one of them failed or someone
some model didn't reach some validation
threshold it wasn't good enough so for
example what happens at Expedia Japan
hotels failed what's the best
alternative model to use in that case is
it Expedia Japan flights or Expedia US
hotels or some totally other model that
seems like unrelated but turns out to do
very well or is Expedia Japan hotels are
so important that we should fail out
completely stop the whole MOT deploy
process fix it and find out what's going
on and that logic is all kind of being
encoded into this put in publish steps
so we kind of have you know hierarchy or
fall backs and so on so here's what the
whole architecture looks like like I
said we're in AWS shop we use air flow
just really kind of kicks things off and
coordinates and keeps track of what's
going on we're snowflakes our data
warehouse it's great so far it's it's
been a real cost saver for us so the
steps along here are the first time you
hit air flow hits s3 is where it
publishes the the jar sorry it wraps up
the jar pushes it up to s3 so it's ready
to use by EMR it then kicks off a whole
series of EMR jobs and in theory you
could just go here and my you know 4,000
models I want to try and go train all of
them and it would spin up 4,000 EMR
clusters it's a good reason not to do
that so instead we do it in chunks so
kind of roughly equal size jobs each of
those goes and reads the jar from s3
does the training does the testing does
the validation and then pushes the
artifacts back to s3 air flow then comes
and says ok keeps track that it's
happened these ones have finished when
the next cohort is ready to go it pushes
up
next cohort and it goes through the
whole training process and all the
results of these things also get pushed
to dynamo that's really just for our
monitoring that gives us a kind of a
persistent view of what model happened
when what feature versions were used
what the future summaries looked like at
that point what was the accuracy and so
on as well as the decision about whether
or not this model was going to be used
and if not what was the other model that
was used in its place so this is the
kind of governance piece of it so that
we can keep track and you know go back
and say on Thursday last week what
happened
and finally the publishing step we just
go and deploy this jar up to ECS and all
the model versions and everything with
the corresponding metadata from the
features are in s3 ready to be cashed up
and this is the piece that kind of keeps
everything in sync the main key point
here is the air flow will fail the whole
process if any piece of it needs to fail
so if some really important partner or
some really important model failed and
we're uncomfortable with publishing that
you know without having that model up
the whole deploy fails and so it's a
consistent or at least at an atomic
deploy
just as an aside we also have this
ability to push that same code to
lambdas we use lambdas quite a lot and
they're great for small small-scale
experiments it's if you wanted to push
the code up there and then you want it
to test against some small slice of
production traffic basically is it like
last a B test before you go live with
something this is a very efficient way
to put something up and tear it down
without influencing the rest of things
we did toy we're just using lambdas for
everything it works it's effective it's
just quite costly so the nd CS is
cheaper okay and I think this is my last
slide so just some things to kind of
keep in mind about what we like about
this so one actually the really relates
to the last talk is that this is the
production environment this is the
production code like the production
infrastructure that we use but as a dev
I I can toy with something and I can use
any piece of it so all I mean all
airflow is doing is saying go trigger
this thing go trigger this thing go
trigger this thing I can trigger any of
those pieces myself and we have like
staging environments where you can spin
up the whole end-to-end thing and you
have dev environments where you can push
up any bit of it so if you want to do an
ad hoc training run somewhere and see
what happens you can totally do that
from your machine
in one command he pushed the lambdas
which is a nice to have the key one for
us is like this will automatically infer
what correct model configurations to use
at least as much as possible right so
the right amount of training data to use
and so on is something that can be
automatically inferred and a lot of the
other configurations that go with it are
just dealt with by try all
configurations it's kind of like the
hyper parameter tuning version of this
we define the fallback logic that's
something that's the business logic that
we have to put in place but it's defined
and it's kind of defined in one place
which is nice
and it also guarantees that every
request will get a response and you know
that response is the best one we could
give you at the time and we know what
what happened what what that response
was coming from so I promise to explain
why we break things up into cohorts
instead of just spitting out thousands
of spark clusters on EMR the main point
here zmr is a shared resource and AWS
will throttle you if you do too many of
them that would be fine if we were the
only ones getting throttled but
meanwhile our data pipelining folks also
use EMR and getting throttled as a
company is a pretty good way to get
unpopular quickly so keeping the number
of jobs you're spinning up to a
manageable size is a good idea it also
proved improves maintainability so if
you if you start to see problems you
don't have to worry about spinning up
the rest of them if the first six fail
in a row you may as well not carry on
with the rest because you know you got
something wrong the key point here is
this is a persistent we keep a
persistent consistent record of every
model and every feature version and
everything that went up so that we can
always go back I can look at it actually
one of the things we're building right
now is just making that kind of nice
with some nice integration for
monitoring and alarms that go off and
having some nice visuals and so on a
random and the key point I want to leave
you with is this is a way of making sure
that the deployments are atomic right if
anything fails or you decide it doesn't
meet your business needs you could just
fail the whole thing and you don't end
up in some weird half state where some
of the things are predicting on the old
version is some of them are pretty can
the new version okay and I think that's
all I have happy to take questions
[Applause]
I'm still a little confused by what you
mean by train every possible model so is
that like you have hypothesis a
hypothesis be you test them they both
seem okay and you production alized both
or is it like oh you have six features
for a model and then you're gonna train
for every permutation of literally those
six features that would be awesome and
my AWS people would love that
no we don't we don't quite do every
model that's that's totally true when I
say every model I mean so for every
partner there are a maximum of four or
five products typically so hotels cars
flights and cruises are the ones we have
to deal with most commonly and then
there's a there's every possible
combination of those four in those four
so there's 16 combinations of things for
each partner that you have to do not all
of them may be actively used but it
turned out to be easier just to train
all 16 models and only use three in
productive like only served requests
from three than it was to like worry
about which of the three were being used
for this one so those that want to say
every model those are the configurations
I mean not the features official other
questions you can just use that mic
return then you say you save the model
do you see the binary object or do you
save some like text instructions or
something like that
yeah great question we serialize the
models so what goes up is a serialized
model and then what comes out of the
feet the record feature extractor is a
serialized feature that's applicable to
that model yeah absolutely don't try to
deploy the model actually that would be
extremely difficult for us because all
the models can be different in the old
system that we had that's kind of what
happened that the model was part of the
static Scala code that got deployed
during the census binary and that meant
you have to use the same features in the
same model for everyone all the time
you
[Music]